it makes me feel sad I think to hear
other stories like that Holly Madison
speaks out for the first time on the
lawsuit that links her famous
ex-boyfriend Hugh Hefner to Bill Cosby
you're very vocal and very open about
your time in the Playboy Mansion and you
write in there that have offered you
drugs at one point do you feel
vindicated because so many people said
that your stories weren't true you know
I don't really know anything about Bill
Cosby per se because I don't know him
but you know it makes me feel sad I
think to hear other stories like that
Holly made her claims about half in her
first book down the rabbit hole though
some claimed she was lying what Holly is
saying is extremely false I'm like where
did it come from I don't know if I feel
vindicated because it makes me feel sad
to hear you know victims stories and
court documents obtained by ET a woman
named Chloe Goines accuses Cosby of
sexually assaulting her at the Playboy
Mansion in 2008 she also claims Hefner
allegedly provided adults under 21 with
alcohol or substances did you ever see
Bill Cosby in the Playboy Mansion no I
met Bill Cosby in passing but I never
saw him at the parties not to say wasn't
there
these days Holly says she doesn't speak
to her ex if you could say anything to
him these days
what what would you say I wanted to say
anything in you I think it's kind of odd
because people ask me that all the time
like do you still talk to him and I'm
like usually when people move on they
don't like talk to all their exes I just
don't think it's appropriate of course I
have fond memories of my time there but
you know move on the 36 year old mom has
moved on she's been busy promoting her
new book the Vegas Diaries about her
life in Las Vegas post mansion it's all
the crazy stories from you know being a
headliner in Vegas and everything I
learned you know through my dating
journeys and you know through my career
and things like that so it's a really
fun time in my life that I'm happy to
share